with Chad Oubre for the town huh I don't
know it's like I just believe in the
work you know right and like if the work
speaks I have to do less explaining no
cuz I would hate for sometimes the
people's assumptions do better for you
than you giving somebody something very
specific so yeah if I'm like hey man
this is our goal and you was like and
you received it as man that's it you
know that's why rather just like that to
work yeah but that's why we're here
because a lot of people may look at 85
south and be like oh they just you know
they got people that are already on
seeing Carlos yeah exactly that's what
people don't get is they think what
people may think oh it just happened
because they know no the work is what I
want to get into there is some I'll say
this there's like nothing we do is not
accident totally yeah like nothing like
there's nothing that falls out of the
sky yeah no so alright so um I don't
need to do something some spell my name
is Terry O'Brien oh yeah are you not a
bottle you know not do I need one okay
yeah we out here and I'm used to you
know your art dude as soon as we met
outside he's like me oh man I don't even
know why we're here you know I'm doing
my Chon here
yeah and I've had Klingon in here like
it's but it's about my doing head you
don't know how headphones work may I was
you know I just I'm usually like when I
have the headphones arms you know we're
doing our commercial
right yeah he's behind the scene I'm not
even paying attention what they're doing
I know that what they're gonna do is
what they gonna do
and then you just you just turn it into
like hashtags and
that's right man oh I don't even do the
social media so a word yeah we yeah yeah
I don't even know how to log into this
awesome unit so I actually hate social
media yeah it's a whole machine yes my
thing man I have to like you know my
role I only like to say position but my
role is more like this kind of
quarterbacking man from the you know
calling from the big picture what does
that mean so you know when you think
about like strategy or anything that you
do especially when you have a plan
there's people that are actually
executing on like the very specifics of
it and then there's somebody that has to
like so I'm top to bottom that the
machine is moving and every button is
being pushing those sort of things so
that's my role I hate to say position
because I still have no problem you know
I'll take trash out and get cars and
drive for people it doesn't bother me
but so you're like you're like the
puppet master I'm not even comfortable
with saying that so no I just you know
from the big picture I just you know I
try to see everything okay I'll just say
I'm not even comfortable saying puppet
master because we all are very we're all
very like included in the process it's
not like hey guys you do this and listen
to what I say
my position is more putting these guys
in the best possible space in place with
the best possible tools in environment
as they can possibly be so they can
exhaust every single talent that they
have how many people are on the team
total I'd say uh let me talk either in
front of the camera I'd say it's four
probably rotating obviously that's
Carlos Chico DC and then behind it it's
myself
our director Joe our audio guy cat a
music director genuine and there's
another camera op Craig nice there's
another one we just brought on this day
so yeah it's about what is that like
eight of us
I don't know my math in the bed yeah you
can tell any rotate man because what'll
happen is we'll go to a city you know
just depending on the space cuz
different spaces you have to shoot
different capture differently so we may
bring one another Kim Robert - yeah like
the live shows and stuff right right and
then um you know we're all working
moving around so Jo may be in LA working
on a project or another camera I may not
be here I mean up here so you gotta have
somebody kind of feel input I mean we
kind of created a system where it kind
of to a degree around this house yeah
you got to have a system in place
especially with all the people you're
working with even the talent alone and
matching up with their schedules that's
yeah man that's mom's car that's
probably the hardest part man because it
was it was our you know it's funny even
saying I remember when cuz we're not
even that open yeah you start like
December of 2015
yes so roughly was going on our third
year but but uh unbelievable I just
remember when it was like everybody had
time like what's our door you know right
right that was it you know and he was
like any matter if it was Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
y'all free let's do it mm-hmm then it
became like you know what's your
schedule like you know and it turns into
get on people's books and calendar
invites and scheduling outs two three
four five months a year so yeah yeah the
evolution man is like I remember it
seemed like when you starting in
December you were almost you were almost
just dumping them you almost like
flooding the streets like crap yeah you
know like they just wanted to get it out
there and then start to draw it back and
build the demand like you just want yeah
that weird oh it's not the strategy
there the strategy was like let's figure
it out and like all of us who felt
comfortable enough to uh we don't mind
figuring it out like in front of people
huh you know yeah so I think some people
take the mentality of well let's get it
perfect whatever the case is but like
you know this isn't like a car we're
building whether specific specs like
changes all the time like DC may go to
LA and see something that's just
inspired him totally different and now
he comes back with a different
perspective or I may have worked on a
project and not known like oh shoot
lighting if you'd like like this that's
that you know so you we all come back
with different perspective and then like
experience and all that helps for it to
evolve and then you just learn how you
make a lot of mistakes on a go which
like expedites the process of getting a
little bit better
yes so what I think what I've learned is
like in turn that mic towards you there
I'm sorry for the people yeah the
culture now right not normally I'm you
telling you bro no normally I'm sorry so
so for us it's more like I look at it
like oh I don't have like the perfect
answer of what it's supposed to look
like but I think when you try a lot of
things you know exactly what it's not
supposed to look like hmm so it's almost
like you know if you like people like
man what's the what's what's your
perfect job were like your perfect
partner you know boyfriend/girlfriend
like most of us know what is not from
like exes or ex jobs but not none of us
really know like man the perfect job is
like clocking at this time none of us
really we just kind of working toward
that so like that's how we look at um
the podcast and we just try to put as
many like best practices around it if
that makes any sense what are some of
the best practices you found to be
sustainable consistency okay yeah so a
lot of people alike jump into it and
like a lot of people to jump into it
like very ambitious with these big goals
and these big desires it may be some
people may be looking for Hollywood
deals some people may be looking for
some money out of it whatever the case
is none of those things come without
consistency so I would say consistency
is like number one and just like pay
attention to the details so like if your
audience is accustomed to a certain type
of audio like make sure your audio is
always clean you know and like people
I've heard podcast where one day the
audio is super clean the next I can only
hear I left ear and it's like man y'all
are getting lazy on the things that
matters the most because if you have
like the content is
they know what they're they're coming to
listen to but you got to provide like
the best you got to give them the the
best output that you possibly can like
every single time even if it's not even
if you don't think it's the best but
like there's the minutes as many people
have come to us and like man this is
that one Psalm like y'all like but you
don't you know you don't know what
people's palates are so that's why I say
consistency man cuz you're like creating
this framework where they you're giving
you're creating a sandbox that people
can play you know you're creating this
there's palette that people can you know
taste tests from and will you in
building it do you listen to audience
feedback and you're like okay they all
have this that's my job I have to okay
yeah so like you know so I when you
think of 85 south so like at least for
me I think about it as like there's this
big umbrella which is 85,000 media right
and then we have like the day of the
life stuff and then we have the studio
podcast and then we have the live show
then we have the variety show right I
think we put out a couple pieces of like
cartoon pieces that were partnering to
work with even from the merchandise side
so like I'm always always looking at
these comments online I'm always I'm
alright even when we go to live cells
man like I try to be the most unassuming
person
oh I'm asking them what they think about
the show who they like today like this
flow today like this cadence all those
things matter to me cause like yeah the
people don't like us we don't really
have too much if they're not coming back
we don't really have too much is that
what you think has contributed to such
big growth is listen to the audience
yeah it's way more like it's way more
about to be I can't tell you how many
times you know will huddle after each
show after whatever project we're
working on it even from the talent side
man what what could we have done better
and it never fails from a 200-seat er to
a you know 800 seater Cedars yeah we
just came back from the walls oh oh my
thing they know in
like it never fails like the talent oh
it's about the people as long as they
can feel like we can touch them it's
cool and I think that's what we've done
man we haven't I said what we done like
what it's not a competition thing but I
know for us specifically internally it's
been about it's been about like making
sure that we're not untouchable okay or
that we're not like we're everyday guys
we're not like Hollywood guys I hate to
say Hollywood guys but you notice that
like that that invisible line when
you're dealing with celebrities we don't
have that so you guys will do meetings
after every show yeah - like what you
can improve on and all that yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah yeah we're not I'd
hate to be like ignorant to what's going
on or too high up you know like flying
too high you know in that private jet
where you're like fifty dot forty
thousand feet up and you don't know what
the ground looks like right right right
try to fly like somewhere in the middle
okay yeah a little million you're
straight I just want to give you in
frame now being the worst brought pause
I know this is our first time here yeah
like I've been working with am on garner
he's been my engineers know that one
audio engineers very no doubt oh dude
yes
must it's an overlooked asset yeah or as
a casting so and now he's built out this
studio at his place where he's hosting
podcasts though so this is the first
time we've been here has a nice setup
man yeah so this is six so we're
figuring out like the camera angle we
wanted to do and all this so I just want
to make sure your your face you said you
like to be unassuming so I wanna make
sure that space is in here right right
no I understand so have we started I was
that was that the intro oh yeah we're
here okay cool yeah we are Church at
this make you so yeah yeah drop the
music playing 85 cities in the building
all right crazy yeah and you say if you
want water that's your water down there
he said this is our fondest water this
is like our Red Bull of you guys know
how to have Red Bull this is fondest
water yeah they made us a custom label
educated escape
like the local spring water no duh
already good okay cool
swell here on different hustles and
that's that's why I won't been wanting
to sit down with you and you told me in
Duncan yeah I kind of pause I was kind
of don't but yeah I'm not really one for
a whole bunch interviews though it's
certain that the fact you even agreed to
this made me I like I've listened to a
bus here I don't like to walk into
anything blindfolded right so when you
told me and I obviously been seeing it
but uh I got that runs our social we got
two guys I kinda have a piece of it
there's like it's a somebody almost
interviewing I mean you're right
whatever
oh my god you know I'm good at man and
then I kind of figured you know I
checked it out and I actually listened
to a bunch of them on the road because
I'm always interesting like information
you know right um one of my you've done
a bunch of really good ones I really
like the one with though what some meds
aren't from County hi
yeah hey today yeah yeah there's another
one you did I can't think who was on it
was it um I would say this to the Carlos
in a daring one Clayton once but it was
one more and I was like man what's my
man you I think you just did it with the
guy that produces specials for rod
Rhodes that's not yeah yeah he does the
comedy special yeah I'm always
interesting that man oh I wanna you know
it's it to be inspired and kind of know
that we're kind of thinking the same
sort of capacity you know so yeah dude
this podcast is all about learning and
as you can hear for sure and sure and I
think oh let me tell you there's another
what's the DJ's name trauma know the one
that was that runs with tip what's my
man's day yeah
KP oh I'm a big fan of like on the low
you know no doubt man um so yeah I'm a
huge fan here so that was super su and I
like I think you got something good man
so I liked how you are it's it's
obviously it's it's the space is comedy
because that's where you come from
Britain it's necessary to have I think
you had a couple of designers when we
had to do branding and stuff like yeah
yeah yeah you have club owners you have
comedians you have producers all this
stuff is necessary man cuz as much as as
it is an art it's definitely a business
and you got to find that balance so it's
necessary especially in comedy that's
our personal thing comedies
being the business of comedy has not
been figured out hmm you know I think
it's like I think there's a there's a
again there's best practices because
what's been taught or what's been done
for so long but I don't know that
there's necessarily like I don't think
people I shouldn't say that figured out
I should say that I don't think it's
been exhausted all the opportunities
have been exhausted like Kevin Hart is
exhausting all opportunities and then
it's like who else yeah and you don't
really think of too many other names you
know what do you think depending on who
you are depends on the opportunities you
have in business for ever has the same
opportunities that's a good question I
don't I don't I don't think it's a black
and white like definite answer I think
that if you are any sort of person that
wants to create for yourself in this
space you need to if you don't
understand strategy you need to connect
with somebody that does if it's a
partner oarfish is paying for that
information
um because like everybody can't be Kevin
Hart obviously everybody can't be like
the biggest guy but I'm like dude if a
comedian I say on the low end is getting
anywhere from 500 to a 1500 or so and
they're able to tour you know and do
some you know X amount of dates a year
like you're doing fine you know so then
it becomes like what are your goals are
your goals and be able to feed your
family then you're doing just fine
are your goals to be like you know to
use comedy to break into radio then you
need to work toward whatever that means
and exhaust those opportunities mm-hmm
are you going on television or these
companies this comedic platform can open
those doors for you so I think that um
yeah I think if you are a personality
you just need to make sure you're
exhausting all your opportunities but
it's understanding where you want to end
up yeah absolutely yeah yeah again like
I'm not there's nothing that any of us
do as a collective and then individually
because I work with all the guys
individually in some capacity but
nothing that any of us do was an
accident even if you make a mistake you
know I think you can purposely make a
mistake yeah cuz I've heard you guys
have like a board
at the studio with in all your different
goals and things like what's all on that
board yeah I wouldn't feel couples
saying that but uh we we uh yeah man
it's it's it's yeah we definitely are
trying to you know hit some attainable
goals mm we've hit some now we're
shooting for a couple more but I think
being able to say you know man I don't I
don't believe in like as I've
experienced more and kind of seen more
and I guess been in different rooms and
has a little a little a very little bit
of access I think that you can you your
world opens up a little bit more yeah or
your perspective let me say opens up a
little more like oh so it is that close
but it is that far so let me work
towards it and then you just kind of
chip out a way back that consistency and
you're like okay we got here faster not
talking or we're not doing this the
right way
so let's let's redirect you know that's
happened to so so in like goal setting
what's a goal you guys made on day one
that you've achieved live shows live
shows yeah yeah I did that's so like the
intent I can't say this like podcasting
wasn't our goal wasn't just to be
podcasters I'm not even really
comfortable saying like the podcast
yeah show yes yes I mean it's a media
company you know oh media come yeah yeah
so you know we and just to always keep
an internal man it was always it so my
hitch my background is I used to work
for Steve Harvey yeah where you guys
start recording - yeah and his studio so
I was on me and my partner Joe who
directs so we'd managed all his his
social is digital he could we worked our
way up obviously but man is all his at
by the time we had left his social his
digital creative anything you kind of
saw come out online from a personal
brand perspective that was that was one
of us well for us for about two years
yeah and then prior to that Joe's
experience was working at Tyler Perry
and then mine was working for this this
agency here in the city that does sports
in entertainment in television and
movies and all those sort of
so yeah to be able to be in some of
those rooms were you able to see
everything from conversations to budgets
what real budgets look like right to
even like how you manage travel all that
stuff matters you know what I'm saying
and I've been able to between the both
of us and then our audio guy he's a
bored-out for Steve so I mean he's doing
that this the highest level you know
he's one first there he's a board
operator for steve-o audio engineer oh
so he manages all that from like he's
like yo this is what he looks like this
is what is supporting like wow he's done
it from the very top you know anything
for 85 it doesn't pay for so and that's
another reason that shows testament to
why you guys are where you are yeah I
mean people behind the scene yeah yeah
like what you know uh it's important for
us on our side on the production side to
be able to match the talent I never want
to feel like I never want to be in any
business relationship cuz and obviously
when you're starting you're trying to
you know people have to give you an
opportunity over some doors we've
definitely had those doors open for us
but as you as you get to a certain level
any business relationship you're in if
you wanted to be an even exchange of
talent time passion um and then payoff
you know I don't ever want to feel like
somebody's just doing me a favor so I
want anytime I'll work would it be like
you'll just do his work and he knows
what he's talking about or he's giving
me the best he's got you know right
that's important for me yeah yeah so I
don't know how we got to this but oh
yeah that's that's kind of you know
what's a lot of this is just the context
for oh yeah oh yeah that's how we got
there is like oh by the way we gain from
working with Steve Harvey we can't work
when Tyler Perry and now we're building
this media company not by accident yeah
oh yeah it was it was extremely
important for us to just be able to do
something for ourselves I'm still out of
set I'm sorry
this is the this is the hustle right
here but you got started in the trap you
know you went from Steve Harvey to the
trap house yeah I mean that was on
purpose - so like perception it's like
me to come up nah I wasn't safe from
there I mean it was a little bit uh
here's a little bit of happenstance and
a little bit of like for like truth this
is the truth
look I'm not a genius all right Carlos
DC Clayton and Chico are the most times
if you've ever met in my entire life
yeah there's an wave you can put those
dudes underwater and they're gonna be
funny like I'm not you can put them
dudes in a trash can it's gonna be fun
you can put them dudes in the Catholic
Church and they're gonna be funny mm-hmm
and they have a chemistry that like you
can't create I can't you can't just put
any piece together make a puzzle work
right you know and like Clayton and
Carlos have known each other since I've
known him since I was 18 years old and
in DC in Carlos were like Carlos was
like the first person that DC kind of
met in that comedy space from Atlanta
and then Carlos and Chico got on while
they're not together so these are like
this is real chemistry that's been
created that's been built over time so
it's not like I'm just this magician
back here man like the President's Award
and this hardship in college right no
I'm not really dead man I went to school
I did go to school you know some credit
there yeah yeah I mean you know I think
I have common sense okay that's what I
think he I don't think I'm smarter than
like too many people so I don't mind
asking questions or trying to figure out
whatever you know whatever case how did
you meet Carlos and Clayton so I was 18
years old and I was trying to get a
summer job before I with the cops cuz I
played football in college I had you
know sports dreams Jacksonville
University right did
yeah okay you got a little research okay
yeah a little bit that's out there I got
your Chad yeah I went to school there
and before I went to school my
girlfriend had a job my ex ex
girlfriends huh
well government times she had a job at
uh do you remember when they had the the
malls the middle of the mall they had
the kiosk and you would sell like AT&T
plan mm-hmm
she had a job there and I was like dude
I wanted to work with his girls I just
want to see everyday right so then we
had to go do training for this AT&T I
couldn't even singular I think it was
called it was singular yeah right so
made so we're gonna go do that man I'm
18 17 18 I had to be 18 and Lois was in
a training right so this is loss of town
loss has hair loss has barely a beard
like the look and this dude like I'm
setting losses never tell he's been
Carlos since this is like the day I met
him mm-hmm funny there's like a
40-person training room or whatever and
Lowe's is just like got people crying
laughing in this room do it and I'm
talking about not like not like trying
to be funny doing just like everything
he says and I was like talking to him
like he was a public baby laughs and he
was like man you crazy it like glosses
from Mississippi I'm from the water so
we already have like that country
backwoods sort of connection and then
I'm like man you'll never see this do it
again it turns out we're working both in
the middle of the mall forgot that malls
called in Kennesaw Town Center Mall oh
yeah yeah and like bro nobody's walking
in there dude he's a bunch of young
people work in the middle of Mars a
bunch of dudes trying to get us some
chicks and they're like me with my
girlfriend and then I see this big tall
dude it's Clayton and it's like me
Clayton and Louis are like trying to
sell cell phone I sold zero cell phone
Clayton and Lowe's soda bunch of cell
phones and they were able to stop
everybody and I'm like dude you got
obviously I don't know me people's head
his job but it's hard to get people to
stop to buy a cell phone
much less you to dude in the kiosk so
you got an extra validate yourself right
and these dudes are stopping everybody
bro young old black white grandma
they don't matter dude like people with
cell phones are really interested in
what they got to say cuz it's so funny
there's a charm
they take over the room man I'm like
these are the crazy but I just want to
get a good laugh so then it turns out so
then I go to school Lowe's has my number
it was funny is loves kind of always
took on it like Big Brother roll cuz he
came to I think he came to Atlanta just
on it just on a whim kinda he's just
left Mississippi we came here and then
OH
so he would always call me man make sure
I'm good doing good asking high schools
going trying to get some tickets but I
was always interesting really get him
playing huh
and then he what position receive I play
some receivers from running back but I
was always hurt and then oh so I come
back my saw after my freshman summer I
wanted a summer job and I didn't want to
do summer school or summer school had
started a job for like a month and he
was working at Dick's sportswear he's
like man I got you he got me a job over
here
I sold no shoes low sold I remember like
I remember like the most like rural
white moms and Llosa's like got these
women captivated mm-hmm
buying all kind of Nike football cleats
for the kids only managed to change me
so we just always stated Tufts on one
day he calls me man might be like a year
later broke cuz loss is about five years
old he calls it like a year ladies like
yeah I think i'ma do comment like man
you bid do it company he's I don't know
like like forever let me know you got it
bro however I could help are you gonna
learn but I help you know I'll tell feel
like the next thing I knew man he did oh
what the who's got jokes yeah he didn't
I think you're building yeah that's the
first time I saw and then he was on home
what's it was it held eight I remember
he called you like no day cuz I hear man
me and Clayton got held my nose was the
hell day and he was like just watch bt
and but he's doing it yeah and we just
quickly yeah so every time I came back
to Atlanta man he always made sure I got
some free tickets I was cool whatever
look girly and I said we've always been
a guest so like that was always my man
first you know like my homie
first and then over the time we were I
was working at the agency for the one
two months
trying to get him a couple opportunity
that kind of fell through just as a
friend in it when I was working for
Stevie that's when we my partner not
kind of took on our own sort of
production thing like man we can do this
you know I always wanted to wait till 30
to be an entrepreneur but we're like 24
my boys like dude there's nothing that
they know that we don't know they just
got more money mmm and they were born
before us oh my yeah you right and I got
fired from his job for asking for a
raise
what job was it I was working the agency
I was working it oh yeah and I asked for
a raise he got fired like a week later
cuz I went straight to the bar how did
you say it were you I would I hate to
say this but I was like oh I put this
whole I put this whole like you know
like presentation together like one
sheet or whatever huh
and I was like I don't want to take
anybody's job I want to create my own
job cuz this is when social media was
trying to like people were trying to
figure I mean still trying to figure out
this is like when it was a new thing and
it was like nobody really knew how to
define it or whatever but I'm like
social media is necessary because
obviously I'm one of the Millennials
that sees the wave or there and I'm like
yeah I want to do this like coordinator
slash social media sort of thing and
this is why this is what the average
person is making I don't want that much
I just want this much a little bit more
than I'm making and he was like have you
talked to anybody about this I took him
out to lunch with my own little money
well the head boss yeah like that that
do be signing my checks I don't like
like you need this this is why you need
it these are all the things that I've
that I've done since I've been here I
start off as an assistant and I'm like
these are all the things I've done so
I've been I've managed budgets I've done
client calls I've done XYZ I've saved a
couple of count so I just I'm not asking
for a raise I'm just asking for a new
position with a little more money and he
was like whoa have you talked to anybody
about this I'm like nah why would I
he was like you didn't talk to your boss
I'm like you know why would I talk to
anybody but you you don't want to sound
gonna say like man just give me some
time I don't think about it I was
alright so the next day my boss calls me
you went and talked to Holly out without
telling me I'm like you don't sign my
texts not knowing that you know ain't no
chain of command oh I'm just ambitious
like bro-down no this is what I want
yeah you know seems like all right yeah
I'll show you we later got fired so from
there I'm like hey Joe doing that thing
he was talking about go ahead and do
that I mean I can only go up from here
he's like I so we started you know
creating for our sale as far as
photography photography
I mean photography videography a little
bit of design is that the austere 80s
out toy poor oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so
uh-huh and that just started off as like
video content or whatever and we were
starting to you know we started there
was a space for like even back I say
back there I'm sure people still do it
but like there were brands that would go
shoot things they would do it event and
they were capture it to give it that
extra sort of feel right in the cases so
you can feel like you were part of it or
you missed out on something and we
started there was a space for that so we
kind of jumped on there based on the
relationships that we had that parlayed
into an opportunity to actually before I
was working for Steve I was working for
as a business partner or Sean McDonald
who was Steve's business manager for
about 25 30 years yeah so I was his
assist I was his assistant whoa carrying
his coffee taking his car to get fixed
getting his mail all the little things
put like bro when you're somebody's
assistant you hear so much right and
you're talking about like you know half
a million dollar but just five million
dollar but it's ten this is like he's
doing this with his eyes closed I was
like I didn't know that there was a
world like this you know so I just kind
of worked for him for a while he
promoted me to work for the company and
then just kept every time I asked can
you do something he's like you know
anything about YouTube yeah yeah get on
YouTube and learn about you too yeah can
you build a website
yeah man get on you tool on Google
idealism yeah you know
hey y'all gonna do photo shoots I'm
looking up three-point lighting and all
this though uh-huh
that's how we kind of work that way so
we did all that to eventually get to
Lowe's when he was hosting cats all the
time
and our my mind Carlos was a funny
person but what I also learned was that
like there's kind of like a brand
presentation that you gotta have for
people not knowing that's what it was at
the time so we'll go to Casa just shoot
not even really know what to do with it
and just kind of putting it out and know
you know here's like a couple years lady
are you hear people talking about this
content I'm like content you know that's
what we've been doing yeah you know you
guys are almost ahead of the way I we
were just doing it I don't know if not
even thinking of yeah we just doing I
don't know if he's headed away so they
know we're doing that doing that doing
that and then uh we was like do whatever
we do is gotta be involved with Carlos
cuz this number one is my man and I'm to
just do you know funniest person in time
I haven't been anywhere obviously but
I've been in a room with a couple of
comedians at this point cuz it's not you
next to us on you Nexus TV like you meet
a lot of people and it's not a
competition thing is just like dude
Llosa's he's that funny mm-hmm you know
so he's just you know we kept creating
and kept Korean and then eighty-five
came from it was actually supposed to be
a radio show d we pitched we wanted it
to be like a Saturday midday sort of
thing like you know cookout barbershop
sorted so like lo so be it was gonna be
a 90s sort of thing with it cuz the 90s
music was making that come back where
they have two radio stations like 102
nine a couple of state yeah yeah and
this is like I've read some articles
saying that they were like popping up
like North Texas had a big wave that was
making it happen to Atlanta and it was
one more state that was working did the
market research yeah are you right I
guess sorry yeah so we pitched it to
Steve and us not knowing any better you
understand it like Steve is up here so
top of the mountain so you for you to
pitch something it's got it he can't
come down too far you know and not
knowing no better it's not a you know it
wasn't a slight to us it's just like
it's gotta make sense because as busier
the years gotta make a lot so we were
like oh you just EP the name walk us
through the door we'll do the work and
like that's not a bad idea so we kept
trying
trying and we just can't make it make
sense so far as I forget it we'll do
what I said
so we're emailing people trying to
figure out who's who at what radio
station nobody would answer email take
our call one guy took our caller won't
say anything he's like man yeah yeah all
right I mean I respect I understand I'm
not writing it I get it yeah you got to
make financial dollars make sense we're
coming from the art side you know so no
radio station would kind of pay
attention to it and then uh we was like
man well why don't we we thought about
internet radio not understanding that
podcasting an internet radio kind of two
different things to a degree and we were
like well what's a podcast how do you do
it like how do you even upload you know
so we were like well who else can we
find that would like match with loes
because it's hard like comedy is one
thing in front of people commenting on
airwaves the whole of the thing cuz like
you don't get the feedback for radio
like until like a day later or with
podcasting until you a week later
sometimes you know you don't really
understand how that feedbacks looking so
on the flipside we were working for
Steve managing his digital and so
reached out to DC's people and we just
wanted to work with him cuz this is but
right before he kind of took a yeah yeah
yeah like he was still doing the rats
people meat thing and he invited us out
there and we were like I don't think
people understand how funny and how that
forget fun just to haunted like people
keep comparing to Chris Tucker and I'm
like not as Jamie Foxx well yeah I was
thinking Jamie Foxx I anybody every
throw
is it a like yeah and this is like what
three years ago when I met for maybe
three four years ago I remember him nav
green a couple of the guys I'm like you
know all these twos are like they've got
something you know so I don't want to
take from that I just want to know if
you want to work with this and this is
how it can work for you so um so I mean
one day after the rads of people think
we were like BT always invited Steve to
everything well every big media kind of
outlet invites him obviously I'm sure so
we would take those credentials and try
to turn it into content because it's
like okay if Steve's not gonna go let's
go on behalf of Steve our radio net
and we'll just put out his YouTube you
know you do the music interviews or the
festival interviews whatever whatever
so BT was doing the Hip Hop Awards in
Atlanta like they always do and they did
the green carpet thing and I'm like well
fly won't you go on behalf of Steve and
beat a correspondent he was like I am i
okay is that easy
so he gave me his numbers like man in
common tomorrow I was like alright call
him the next day he pickups I'm like man
I got the bill he called that like he's
late like what's up brought my bed I was
sleep come pick me up like I some meat
you know pick me up all right take the
puppy the car I got a car with his way
we went today and I think it's still on
Steve's channel somewhere but it's D
have you seen a YouTube video where he's
like interviewing a bunch of people on a
green carpet yeah that's us we produced
that shot that and uh our goal was to
show it to Steve and be like look this
is the next wave right put these boys
under your own brother we got access to
him cuz he's a really I got it was fly
loves a couple other comedians in again
you got to make it make sense and I
guess it doesn't make sense him at the
time was like we're gonna keep working
the fact even gave you time you could be
like hey Steve I have an idea for it oh
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah absolutely we
don't even we don't we don't in the keep
in mind we're not the guys that's gonna
come to him with anything that we
haven't vetted all the way through I'm
cuz we are we've seen those people that
come to him Steve I got this idea but
what they really mean is I need your
money or I need your brain Anees or
resources versus like you know meet me
here we can make this grow to a bigger
how do you thoroughly vet an idea uh for
what it depends on who you dealing with
you know cuz you got to think about what
you're asking for if you're thinking if
you're asking for him we never really
asked for any finances it was more about
we just need that platform one of my
balls and it's gotta mix and then second
if we need those eyeballs how does it
make sense for you whatever you ask like
I believe in giving way before I had
boom so for him it was like his return
was all right man if we bring this to
you now you're the Godfather of like the
new wave of talent and now you're always
good even when you walk away so you're
the guy to introduce DC Carlos Chico
Clayton any whoever else we got access
to that's not even to find s like a
legacy thing that yeah oh yeah that's
bigger than finances so he was always in
you know it's we still have a good
relationship but you still you gotta
make some stuff make sense make more
sense into the details which I'm not
really comfortable here but so that's a
that's a good note for like anybody
who's wanting to pitch an idea to
someone his first vet it and think about
what is in it for them and answer yeah
absolutely bro doesn't as a person your
mission absolutely cool cuz people come
to us with stuff and like I know what
it's like for somebody to turn you down
means how so I hate I'm like do you like
you got it I'm nobody you understand
when you come to these guys he's will
pack is he Steve Harvey's he's Kevin
Hart's like yours number one understand
you're in the room right and like you
gotta understand these guys schedule man
like there are some people in like this
is just how capitalism works there are
some people that do not have any time to
wait like you're thirty minutes with
them could have blew them a check cuz
that they could have had they could have
turned on a bunch of meetings that was
as quick as let's sign a deal mm-hmm so
for you to even get that opportunity I
understand it and it's not nothing to be
nervous about but just understand that
like make sure that you've thought about
how they're gonna win way before you're
gonna win so if you thought about that
for them you can always back into you
how you win cuz sometimes the winners
I'm just I'm next to you there's a win
in there but like if you're dealing with
these people who have done the work who
have gone through the process who are 10
5 10 15 20 years into this but I've seen
it all you know so make sure that
there's some payoff for them make sure
they're not doing you a favor so is that
how the whole Diddy situation came to be
man um that that was kind of crazy that
just came from mom she's kind of doing
the work the
I'd be lying if I mean he came to us we
don't really yeah we don't really reach
out to people
I'll be honest with you like after the
Steve thing we took it on ourselves be
like you know what he's gonna keep
working you know cuz I believe in we
believe in DC Carlos Chi going to
Clayton that much y'all are gonna be
dumb guys in no time no doubt and that
when I say those guys those guys that
like the rest of the world has
acknowledges though that we've already
ignited mm-hmm so we kind of took on
that mentality like what does keyword
will be I you know so and you were right
yeah well I mean look we're not even
nothing you know we got along with Bob
serious it like you know we got a long
way to go bro so I'm not we're still
working but by all intents and purposes
so how does P Diddy reach out to you is
this like somebody like Puff Daddy you
know it takes two phone calls you can
get T he did get you know but yeah I
mean but you get a calling like oh it's
P Diddy you're like wait what yeah yeah
no he called he has he called fly and a
fly caught me and I'm like hi bro but
you gotta stay like a bunch of people
get that fly for like the craziest stuff
we just not really like focal about it
you know so he resided here and you know
but it's a thing like we you know again
like it's a it's a big deal for me
personally to be able to sit at the
table versus somebody doing me a favor
at this point in like business so it was
it was a mutual thing you know and it's
like you know even if nothing comes to
that bros like we're on the radar you
know and it means something so that was
cool that was super cool like this I'm
the anybody that knows me personally
I'll tell like Puff Daddy talked me out
dance bro so though you go way back with
do like ah man I like role isn't coming
up man like being a kid watching MTV
Jams like the real MTV Jams before you
go to school it's just seeing puff and
Mason and
massive peeing like all them dudes from
back then as I our crazy they kind of
see there but you gotta you know you got
to be professionally you got to put that
professional side I don't like you got
act like just another person you played
it cool I have to bro yeah have to I
mean all of us did in Lake he's a human
when it's all said and done but I think
talking about a dude it's like about to
be a billionaire on his home
so a he just wanted to he just wanted to
meet you guys and get a photo what like
why would he reach out and use his
valuable time he's one of those bright
like you said yeah well I think you know
I've also learned to when you kind of
get in these spaces
a guy like himself who's really smart
with what he connects himself with I
think that was you know just kind of
getting a feel for everybody and you
know just seeing what's going on cuz
it's one thing to see it on you know on
social media on online or whatever and
there's another thing right okay so he's
this is this is the human behind gotcha
I think that's important so you got your
in his office like he did I you out to
just come oh we're already gonna be in
LA so we just had to make it make sense
very bright because it was supposed to
happen probably months ahead but again
the blessing with 85 it's created
opportunities for if I kind of Oliver
mmm-hmm so we're not you know we're all
of us a lot more especially like Louis
fine
Chieko those guys but I think one time
Ian's over doing this project we were
working on um we Shack and then there
was a loss was on the road no time DC
was going Treo so we just had to make it
make sense for everybody that's huh
so his revolt coming up is that the move
I don't know you know just hanging out
just I don't know that's what's so dope
about podcasting is like have you heard
of Atlanta monster oh it's a podcast
it's one of those crime drama podcast I
have heard of it but it went like super
viral it was like number one it goes
crazy right I have a frickin they do
like they were I don't want to say like
Netflix but it's like a place episodic
episode yeah Atlanta monster is like
season two I think yeah my boy in LA is
crazy but I know you took I just went to
a talk they did at switch arts here in
Atlanta swishah and they were talking
about how they develop podcasts now TV
and mind that's dope yeah how they
develop it loud speaker network try that
yeah you guys are on loudspeaker right
we're not we have a participant okay
yeah
we have relationship with it but uh
there can they're connected yay we got a
good relationship with you um what'd you
call it
loud speaker was trying that with the
guy Chris tomorrow who is a producer
over there and you know combat jack rest
in peace right they were producing these
almost docu style audio pieces mm-hmm
telling but what they would do is I
can't take it a guy's name he passed he
was an executive a big record executive
but uh they were doing him like a docu
style leading up to like his his work
and but they would take like a fat joe
whose work with him so that's his
episode whoever else is working with him
and be like a eight episode series that
was kind of dope I don't know how well
it did what are you trying to do that
lady five is long-term transition to TV
I just content just create content yeah
so I mean I think there's the
traditional mythology is like there's
television in there's radio but the
Internet has opened up so much because
here's the thing that we pitched Steve a
while back I remember watching on what's
his name Jerry Seinfeld changed the game
in my mind yes and I don't think I think
people are just now catching up to that
but I remember watching uh uh comedians
in cars getting coffee right and it's
crazy seeing that come out because he
put that out in like at the very same
time I remember being in Chicago with
with mr. H and it was me and um his crew
and my mom and Joe you were like yo you
are like the coolest doing or by people
you touch a certain type of demographic
everybody listen to what you have to say
cuz you like the OG you're still
relevant to like that 40 year old in my
audience I'm talking to you well this is
us talking to him talking to who talk to
Steve Oh Steve I say mr. mr. H yeah it's
like wait mr. H turn my folks this yeah
yeah yeah we're like dude how dope would
it be if you're like in the room cuz he
loves cigars you goin all your favorite
cigar spots and whatever city you're
interviewing and just kickin it with
like your guys and I we say that like
two months later comedian cars came car
will come god I'm like stupid yeah so
like obviously we didn't know at the
time we're just kicking cool ideas like
he loved it we just I don't know what
that budget is like at that time I don't
know what that costed do that mm-hmm
it's just you know us in the room now
this isn't pitch room this is like just
kicking it room with mr. H right like
hang with mr. Cooper well he's a man
there were some days he would just have
us come around you know just for
experience and exposure they knew you
know you dude that's a blessing so he's
like man what you think about some
content idea well I got this one idea
that those are always encouraging though
like I've had jokes I've like starting
to develop and then I'll see them on
like daily show or something
yeah like oh well that's cool it shows
you're at least thinking on the right
track
yeah well look man I think to think
about ideas is like some people believe
that you should hold on to your ideas
until it's the perfect time and I
understand that thought process likes to
think that way but I believe that like
you people talk about you get your ideas
stolen or joke stolen or whatever they I
understand that but I personally believe
that like I look at it like putting up
shots mmm and like sums gonna fall and
you become a better shooter with the
more shots you put up cuz I've there's
ideas that I know for a fact they're
like that's my idea bro you've seen how
that yeah that I've seen like executed
they don't like come on you know it is
like but it but it doesn't bother me man
like it doesn't it's not like I feel
like I've been blessed with that you
know with that gift even from the
strategy side are you from afar it looks
like okay these dudes are just churning
out a bunch of content by the time right
how how calculated is it is it like
okay on this day I'm releasing a photo
on this they were releasing YouTube
video at noon yes the calculation is
more than just like the consistency okay
yeah yeah the thing died you need a
reset I might yeah yeah I'm cool it's
got a couple more minutes here well I
got I actually this is the fries day you
cut me is why I couldn't run so I'm
actually free all day broads got a
workout at 6:30 I hope I don't sound
like you need it's a probability they
kept telling me to do so they see us out
here no man it's like you know
interviews a good thing I'm just like
cool I don't think I'm like the best
orator you know you're doing great buddy
Thanks great mister mister see I'm just
gonna start no I'm not even cuddle with
mister anything yeah I'm good appreciate
that but even with it with a hot breath
I've been really leaning into lately
like the content side and trying to find
new ways to generate as much content I'd
say listen man I think you have
something like I'm I wouldn't just had
to say that cuz I've listened to a
couple of good Park well the ones that
I've been taking the time listen squirt
bro listen honestly hot breath um be
honest hot breath is what I wanted
eighty father be it was like hell no
like I wanted it to be like the rap
radar for comedy you know was I'm like
I'm a guy don't listen I remember being
like somewhere through college when like
YouTube was a
blowing up mm-hmm and dude I've watched
Jamie Foxx interview like it's you know
like I'm that guy to watch all those
Denzel interviews you know watch social
interviews like that stuff is crazy
people puff talking about how him and
being like I was I love that stuff man
so when I was like man we need to
interview comedians we need to have Deon
Cole we have Steve and ask him those
stories for the night man
that's corny I was like all right I
guess you right you know what is like us
not knowing you know me not even
understanding the full breadth of like
well yeah but what you're doing is a
space for it do it like there's a real
space for and I think you're doing it
right cuz like it what's tough is like
it doesn't matter how awesome Atlanta is
because I really believe in Atlanta we
don't have that uh foundation and like
New York hair or that LA has like we're
getting it I know people's out of time
and Lana's gonna be it but what that
really means is like in 10 years maybe
mm-hmm in 15 years maybe I understand
like LA has been doing this and there's
a reason you have to go to LA to do a
lot of things there's a reason you have
to go to New York to do that thing even
Chicago it's like what's your give you
if you were doing what you're doing in
New York or LA duh I think the eyeballs
would be a little bit bigger than or the
perception let me say that I shouldn't
say eyeballs I don't know what you don't
put their perception yeah cuz like you
know podcasting is what it is when it's
all said and done and you can kind of
play with you continue with it to a
degree but like at the very traditional
sense of podcasting like you're not
doing nothing that anybody in New York
LA isn't doing you know what says I
listened to how I built this I love that
yeah that's exactly what this is right
from an Atlanta perspective
I shouldn't say Atlanta but like a
regional perspective and like with the
comedic sort of foundation exactly no
yeah yeah it's just a comedy if you ask
me audio sounds this is good
presentation is
is good you know so so what would you do
to cuz I feel like you know I've done
over 130 now and I feel like I found my
system as far as creating episodes and
turning them out weekly and generating
guests but yeah the the eyeballs man
yeah poser with a strategy there have
you figured out who your audience is
I think it's comedians younger younger
comedians looking to learn about comedy
and how they can get better at it yeah
yeah so I can give you our perspective
right yeah yeah like I'm pretty familiar
with our audience at this point so we
don't like really kind of leave our base
so like when you're thinking about your
audience and how to grow it number one I
think you're doing a lot of the right
thing I don't I wish I had a big secret
for you
the consistency is like the secret your
next step maybe opening you up to a
little bit guest that may have it like
bigger visibility because I think your
content is really really good like in
all seriousness so it may be like a
guest situation for you where it's like
there's that one guest that kind of blew
me up cuz I know you got that in PR like
you got the love from MPR like yeah
you're doing its the content is there
it's just patience I guess and
concessions and then like you know it
may be that one guess if I could mr. H
yeah right if that Dr Cole comes in or
whoever the case is that can kind of
like break it open cuz you don't know
when like the quote-unquote break cause
like I remember when like I was like oh
shoot people aren't listening to it
what was that moment um I want to say
when we did uh we did an episode we did
this episode with what's-his-name it was
with NAB it was with DC no that wasn't
an episode it was with DC Lowe's in a
piece of mall that's what it was and I
don't know what she did that was I think
she had just hit that kind of viral
thing right at the right time I don't
even know
she was at the time to be honest with
you I was like oh you're the girl that
did whatever whatever cuz Louis and DC
are connected to it they brought it and
then like we hit at the right time she
did the interview in that like took off
on YouTube man people are couldn't
listen to it kinda mm-hmm and then we
just then I think nav came not either
never Manuel Hudson came on next and
then we were like okay we gotta you know
find a little bit of consistency and I
were pushing this out and then we
thought I don't wanna say took off but
that's when I was like at that I think
we're turning the corner and then when
we got to start doing those tribal songs
and we got away from week we started
focusing again on like the content and
less about the guests and making it more
about getting better with DC and Carlos
mm-hmm cuz I got up for at one point I
was trying to keep getting guest at the
guest house like Minnesota doesn't
depend on guest like we don't these guys
themselves can be funny for hours on
Howard as long as they got the win for
so once we kind of focus on that and
incorporating like we got a little bit
better with like some of our segments I
say segments but loosely with our
segments as far as like some topical
things cuz that helps online we mean
like just giving people direction or
yeah well I say I mean like topical as
far as like say Trump do so I'm Craig I
making sure they talk about it or you
know so with all that online stuff are
you guys strategic down to even how you
word the titles and maybe even the the
tags of the videos and like that SEO
approach yeah we have experience in SEO
you guys get into all that what are some
tips on that what do you own the
Internet you know like I'm asking for
the sauce no no no well yeah I can't get
so I was told not to give away so go do
the interview but don't tell him
anything that would give away to South
No
look I'm not the genius SEO do like our
technical guys you know home but I know
that day that's what they do yeah yeah
yes they they focus on like like that
technical SEO keyword search and all
that stuff and I definitely know it
helps yeah you don't know anything about
it though not as much as I shoot for now
yeah these the launch codes you can't
like giving away the launch now I don't
know you know well what for like a for
let's just say for like hot breath in
general or a comedian trying to build a
brand right your brand is on point like
every it's just every detail is
accounted for what are some tips for
somebody who's like well why isn't what
am I not getting more successful what
kind of tips do you have that may be big
mistakes you guys made that we could
learn from man I would say uh I would
say if you're looking externally you'll
probably make it that's probably the
first mistake you're making trying to
figure out what everybody else is doing
hmm I was like looking internally and
then if you're gonna look at what
somebody else is doing it's like if
you're trying to draw some inspiration I
understand that but as far as like
trying to figure out what somebody else
is doing like I would say look in turn
that's what we've done
we don't really I don't really know what
too many other people are doing other
than like what we're doing hmm cuz I can
tell you all the mistakes that we've
made and then I can I can tell you how
we got better with that from how we put
out I mean even little stuff like making
sure your audio is recorded all the way
through you know how to travel them how
to do merchandise item make sure your
website is clean clickable it it looks
good on a desktop
it looks good on the phone and iPad you
know all that stuff you know we have a
little bit experience in all that so I
would look internally first man and then
again figure out like what you're trying
to do some people are trying to make
some money okay how do you go get some
advertising dollars you can do that
independently which we've done you can
go partner with some advertising
networks loudspeaker doesn't audio boom
does it
I was a couple other one advertised cast
doesn't look up look at look into those
opportunities I'm looking into building
some numbers Facebook has some
algorithms twitter has amino I G has
somehow good reasons he can figure out
and they kind of go from there man
honestly podcasting is like not an easy
thing yeah I wish to work I wish it was
man I wish I could be like Brody's as
easy as this but it's not so that's why
I say like you uh you need to know to a
degree what you want to do when you're
doing is we knew exactly we're going to
do when we created it wasn't just about
podcasting for us so even I will say
this for the first leg I don't think we
saw $1 for like the first eight months
but he's okay I would not go so you know
our goal was to do what we were doing at
the time
mm-hmm in making a sense of how did you
figure out those algorithms oh man just
a lighter well look I got we got some
real nerds in our teams to row we're
like you know I wish it was as simple as
like me which is gene like but we'll be
up all night hunting stuff I mean Louis
will be sending us links and articles
like this is it's important for me that
all of us are pretty educated on both
sides like I'm asking them you know on
their side that yo dude there's a wide
stage feel good as it stays too deep is
the audience like you know what kind of
spaces do you like to be in so I can
understand from your perspective and
they can say well we're explaining them
you know apparently merchandise and how
to cut some commercials and all that
stuff on our side and why you're doing
everything we make sure we talk
everything - but we talk about
algorithms man that's something that's
like there's nothing that Google you two
can teach you and then you got to find
it for you so I said what I say find it
for yourself
that's not that mean like what works for
you because what works for us may not
working okay yeah cool yeah I mean we're
like but we're really we're nervous bro
like you just I don't really do too much
bro
I don't really do too much other than
like I'm like obsessed with work
and this is your full-time full-time
well we work for our sales full-time
yeah so like 85 takes a lot of time
obviously to keep that machine running
but what me and my partner do is um we
have a production company or I call it a
Content company called at or t7 so we've
created for Steve we've created for a
red bull you created for Shaq we've
created for all the black men of Atlanta
um a couple other brands Cox you know so
we do something there sometimes it and I
as I talked about maybe I should tell
more people that but yeah yeah I don't
even advertise aside I need to update it
man and then we work personally with you
know personal brands as far as comedians
so like Chico were putting his site
together um Darren we've built his site
I love Darren by the way he's great like
guys a hustling man yeah he thinks like
an entrepreneur um Billy Sorrell that's
my man yeah he's been on here - that's
my man um who else we bill for no buyers
you can white people know we can def
okay I have no problem white people I
love black people
I understand yeah it's not our time yeah
crazy
who else man so we you know we built we
worked with global soul the sneaker guys
yeah we built their website um so you
know we do that on our time on our spare
time and then what I'm really trying to
get into is like deciding more apparel
and stuff like that for people that's
like that's like my little fun thing so
yeah that 85 South logo is insane man I
mean we're actually we're redoing it
what yeah so it's funny that I
appreciate you liking all this stuff but
actually I hate everything that we do
because it's not working right
no it's just like I don't know man is
I'm always like man it could be a little
bit better I'm probably getting all that
guys nerds with that
man yeah so is cool but we missed a
couple days could always be better right
yeah some point you just got a yeah we
did it yeah man we used to yeah yeah so
we work with karma doesn't work all
right
so yeah so like you know let's food I
don't have a job that's what you're
asking like I don't clock in anywhere so
like we clock into ourselves yeah and
then we you know we working on some
personal stuff with Lowe's
we've already directed and produced a
special for she going brand we kind of
like tag-team that you know does
branding require that internal approach
like if somebody yeah yeah man let me
say it one thing does excite me is like
brand approaching strategy that's like a
lot of stuff well let's get into it
yeah yeah so what was your question well
just you mentioned that people should
look inward instead of outward yeah
absolutely man
anything with a brand new bed broke
cause like man like Carlos is not DC
right and DC's not Darren and Darren's
not Clayton in none of them are
eighty-five south show individually and
at all like there's to be this clear
separation and a little bit over that
but always look internal man cuz
authenticity is what's gonna help you
last and not age mmm you're gonna make
it through the times when it matters so
like nothing matters more to me than
authenticity even when I was working for
Steve you know when you're at the level
that he's at there's a lot of brands
that are connected with you so you gotta
be very PC about a lot of stuff but I
think if you can kind of dig on his
YouTube page you'll see like a lot of
the cool stuff that came out came from
us and we wanted to make it relatable
man like palatable in like y'all just do
this dog yeah yes you are getting off
for private plane but that's okay cuz
you work for and ya you are smoking a
cigar but that's what you do when you're
in your pastime know your you know
downtown and like we had oh he wants to
do his blog site at one time we built
this whole blog site for him oh and just
that site was at one point I think it
was up for like a year or two it was
doing like 2 million visits a month I
won't
if it was crazy he's doing bro so even
in brand identity yeah how how in depth
like with the branding I've heard you
need to like almost create like an
avatar of who is your target yeah I mean
I hear that man look that's really good
industry talk and I'm not mad at it it's
necessarily when you in those rooms cuz
I've had those conversations but I mean
it's like I'd like to say I'd like to
consider myself like a creator first in
like a entrepreneur second so I always
try to put the art ahead of the business
and some stuff just kind of you know I
was talking about like best practices
like there's the stuff that feels right
in within that feel right of that art
let's make sure it lies were some best
practices or get as close as we can so
you don't lose some you know okay so
yeah you can do all those things bro you
know in target audience in and then you
break down your audience into
demographics you know right right you
can do all that and that's cool and
that's necessary because you don't want
to take shots in the dark but some stuff
like if you don't connect and it just
don't connect none of that stuff matters
and I think a connection comes to like
that sixth sense
you're like your personal instinct yeah
taste is a word taste yeah okay
taste is word that I like to use all
right cool yeah yeah you guys expanded
the brand into like merchandising which
you know I mean I've I've had two shirts
at one time and like this water here but
like none of it uh it's a good print and
it looks like a like a 70s sort of
eighty sort of day oh cool and then if I
really bought it but that's okay that's
okay though it's a good that looks like
something you find over in criminal
records so that's don't word yeah oh so
it's just it's not timely yet it'll
it'll get its time get listen listen
there's some of our merchandise that I
knew was gonna be a hit and I'm like it
might only one that like this what was
that bro we did this song we did this
t-shirt this Outkast t-shirt rendition
we like DC I think I problems it for the
tour
no we did it for
we did it for uh did it like last year
and it was like to stank on your album
in DC was uh Roger 3000 and Carlos was
big boy and like we put it online like
nobody but did you make it did you
design it so what I don't have the time
to sit there and design like I used to
like getting illustrator I'm not the
best design I'm beyond me so we have a
guy that we partner with this dude is
like I'm like bro this is the
inspiration these are this is the
palette that I'm looking at the colors
that I want this is what I wanted to
print on but this is what I need to look
like and we'll go through a couple
renditions a couple edits that's it
let's do it
but nobody bought that one the outcast
yeah I'm like oh I put the custom tags
on it bro I put the choice headed back
the package it was dope hard bro hey LA
I guess the orders weren't feeling it
but they loved that freaking brazen man
that and that's what I've heard is
sometimes and even with like musicians
it's like the hit song was the one they
didn't like wasn't the one they thought
was gonna be a hit flopped but the one
they just threw out there is one that
yeah and like that's - that's the
business side of it yeah the art of me
is like how was i but the people loved
it
I'm never going they ain't about me you
know just listen to the people that's
yeah man I will say this one we just did
the House of Blues one know that that's
like cuz I was when I try to create
apparel I try to do P cuz I remember man
like you know there's a vintage shot
right there and he said Lana the UM the
vs. place and uh you walk in there and
like there's some tea I mean Rob bought
like a UH I got from him like a
looking's a comedy t-shirt that they had
from like years ago obviously Namit I
bought it for like 15 bucks and I
brought it to Steve on my yard it's
yours man Wow alright he was like man
tall where'd you find it I told and like
I want our church to feel like that when
people cuz you can remember that moment
you know so when we design when I design
I try to I try to create stuff like that
that feels like that and like you know
that's what the outcasts won't felt like
that these it wasn't a hit it fell that
hurt but the House of Blues won't feels
like that uh-huh
cuz they had a whole thing where they
call
like a bootleg tea cuz we didn't get
actually approval for that t-shirt until
like eight minutes before the show
started
Wow had to run it up the ladder illegal
and all that stuff but which gives him
more like a little story so of course
man and I appreciate ya go that yeah cuz
I think about like our gold man is like
ice inside global we're working like in
the same answers like Master P we're
just doing comedy or um like rap without
records like they were independent you
know they did it on they own and they
put up their own money I lost so many
old money but they're in full control of
what they're doing yeah where it's all
about partnerships and we're not waiting
for the you know waiting for anybody
else so that's how I'm in that so when
you when you set these goals just to
wrap it up here and looking at maybe
what your goals are now in were you like
you said after shows you guys will
huddle up and talk about what went well
what didn't we improved on do you guys
have monthly like audits were you like
okay we have this goal to achieve in
what six months do you like that way yep
sure they're not timetable ones it's
more so like for instance like I wanted
to put I will say this goal was to put
like a tent city tour together that we
booked on our own producing their own
travel on our own and we've I think we
got one more City we're about there now
so to one's his mind that'll be it that
like in the play that's a goal um cuz in
what you do is the biggest strategy is
you take that he's like hey whoever
we've done it ourselves look what we've
done
so let's do this for real mm-hm you know
yeah so that's how we put I can you know
the small fish is for the bigger fish
we put goals together so even with a
perilous like hey we want to move X
amount of pieces by X amount of day so
we can say hey whoever look what we've
done
gotcha so you do set a deadline for like
let's say we want to sell a hundred
shirts in the first month mm-hmm yeah
well yeah the deadline is more about
being able to I say deadline but like
that's him within a time frame of like
at or something like that
but it's more of like we'd even knowing
other people oh yes it's our valued even
like subscription goals like we wanted
to hear we wanted to hit a quarter
million it I think we hit it right in
time like a couple months or years when
we realized what we were right right
right
I said quoted me 100,000 like well sure
okay well we're pacing at this but let's
try to get 100 buddies and then you see
hey all of a sudden come subscribe come
subscribe that becomes like like a thing
for us what I mean is yeah I mean we're
not doing too much isn't that nothing's
like falling on this guy it's all
strategic you're looking at analytics
and everything yeah I mean some stuff I
mean look when you got guys like Carlos
and DC right that is your talent some
stuff they're gonna do and you got to
catch up to it that's the truth we just
have to have the camera pointed at them
when yeah like some stuff they do you
like okay we got a scramble to put it
together you know but there's not too
much like there's a real framework and
foundation like Lois in DC aren't
oblivious to what we're doing
hmm and vice versa I'm not even
comfortable in a relationship like that
so I've been around where the talent
doesn't know what's going on they just
being funny or just being talented I
think they're having that connection and
that investment into the whole project
it creates that authenticity it is a
trust
sure there's a level of trust that comes
that layer Trust is the most important
thing mm-hmm you know because your
decision-making changes when you can
trust somebody totally you know you know
so I think that's that helps to there's
a comfort there that you can just he's
got it and I can do my thing and his lip
trust and their peace let me say peace
peace comes from late I can trust that
first I'm glad you trusted me to do one
of your interviews man not as cool you
know you uh you looked at hot breath
like you wanted 85s have to be that no
look I think it worked out for you
though doing our vote no but now what's
she doing is dope man I would continue
to do it if I was you know I'm not
coming I'm I'm in yeah I'm not quitting
I just look at me to maximize the output
boy I'm a mess around and be something
with
and then like and then if you just like
you know say you expanding outside of pi
say you partnered with um say you became
like the official interviewer for those
that comedy fest what they do not hear
yeah laughs it's cool laughing school
you could partner with them and do
something there's your there's a reach I
may not be the interview right you know
I'm saying or if you part what's that
local outlet here creative loafing right
yeah I've connected with ya pardon
wouldn't talk they've got to reach yeah
you know and you touch like that
audience that's palpable what it makes
the most sense so and then like I don't
know man like all them festivals why
wouldn't you pull up to those festivals
and get those interviews just become
part of the media like you can frame it
how you need a frame boom that's what
you get that access that Joel buyers may
not get by himself which is fine just
understanding where you are but if you
become media and get your media outlet
for whatever festival comes through here
you know Atlanta has X amount of
festival why wouldn't you do that that's
what I was asking earlier man strategy
what do I do
put me on the spot I think about it for
thing well I'm glad that came around but
yeah I didn't like that t-shirt is dope
I think you have a website I think I've
been school I have a website the podcast
doesn't have like it's own website but I
have a widow borrow buyers call me doc
yeah yeah man anything like oh I mean
your social well I think I think what
you gotta go I listen to it I don't
listen to everything nobody ever does
yeah like people will say people go in
and out on everything
yeah with the time the tide won't roll
in and out but yeah yeah II listened to
you and you keep up with your uh what's
your viewership and audience on it I
started to recently crush just because
I've hit a plateau and I'm like really
okay it's like how can I break to that
next level now how do you own the
systems in but now it's just the
awareness how do you can't ask me the
SEO stuff man that's the sauce no no no
no they ask you how do you uh how do you
get you how you how do you calculate
your feedback what are you commenting
okay either online or in person like
last night I did three shows and at two
of them somebody came up in like two
that interview did as those perfect man
I need but that stuff but that's thought
that keeps you going man oh man yeah
keep I'm telling you man like more if
you fly and Lowe's had to tell me that
for the longest bro people trust me but
then like I probably said I probably
wrapped because I can talk for everybody
I wrap it on this man like I think the
biggest thing that's been for me this
year is like I'd like to feel like the
people that I've been around or I've
been had been blessed to meet what
separates them from everybody else is
like this pace and they have a pace that
like is it their pace hmm but I think
that pace comes from confidence and I
think confidence comes from making a
whole bunch of mistakes right in those
mistakes come from taking a chance so
I'm like okay taking a chance I made a
mistake got a little bit of confidence
so let me figure out my pace yeah cuz
I'm telling bro if you walk into the
room with will Packer you like I
understand why he's will affect you walk
into the room wait Puff Daddy like dude
there's a reason this is what he just
controls the room and he has a Lowe's
has a pace I'm Steve Harvey has a pace
man Kevin Hart all these guys we've done
work with Shaq has a pace bro and I help
City seven seven - but he's a most
straight-up mobile
dude genius bro right oh yeah and like
I've been blessed to like just get all
this free game from these two Wow
you know so it's like these guys have a
pace about themselves that I think hard
like I don't think hard work is that
thing I think that's I think hard work
is a thing of like the 50s as far as
like physical hard labor like this
you're working right now but this is my
hard work about how we're used to it
being defined so now it's like let me
find my pace within his hard work
because like some people work hard to
like Stock Exchange is I really our work
are you sweating when you're like moving
money around and making more money
losing some money it's just a pen so
pace is my thing 85 I think is finding
his pace though well dude thanks for
sitting down and sharing that with us
man
I knew you had a lot of game really when
I meet you outside you like I don't
really have much to say you know and
then this is turning to over an hour so
yeah okay I'm glad we could crack open
chat here not appreciated man yeah you
should have
whoo you should have on is a DC he's the
only one that hasn't done it from a t54
yeah yeah I asked these he's a genius
he's no I've already researched him I'm
ready
that dudes a genius bro some people have
already researched that so in the day if
they're like I'll do it an hour I'm like
yeah let's do it
I asked him if you wanted it's cool this
is cool room I appreciate him I
appreciate you what were you gonna say
before who do I need on here you said oh
I was gonna say somebody I was like man
it'd be really good I'm sure I'll take
you for it was it wasn't somebody with a
dat fire the comedian I can't remember I
cut you off to shoot my shot on nothing
hey it's all good shot man go forward
what keep shooting boats go going one
day I asked him I know no problem man
yeah yeah yeah and if you think of that
person let me know cuz you never know
that I would yeah this is cool I listed
the one you deal with my boyhood uptown
not of town on what's the comedy club of
the Gwinnett Atlanta comedy theater Gary
Gary Gary yeah yeah that was right after
the Steve Brown situation that was crazy
yeah yeah yeah that's crazy there's a
lot of game in that one Steve's a duck
in Merced that was crazy I like Steve
yeah he was on here too he's cool yeah
he came one so he was on the show yeah I
listened to that one to research man all
that good I was thinking of I was like
man it - it really does research now
hope you know great all I did was all I
found with you on connected with 85
South was like that time you guys did
that show where it was wack and you
almost didn't even think about doing the
show like I don't there apparently
there's a show back in the day that
nobody showed up
oh okay whoa now you're sounding a House
of Blues but what happened on that
man dog all right so look without giving
too much information away we had a show
so a lot of times it wasn't an 85 South
show it was supposed to be but budgeting
whatever whatever and this way you just
gotta trust your six cents but I didn't
I just went for tea anyway man we're
good we got it the guy was most man
you're gonna learn as you do enough
business you're gonna learn who's
serious and who it doesn't take long to
figure out who's serious about you you
can be polite about it gonna be rude but
this dude like there was too many like
hiccups but I was still like let's just
do it
and the fellas is like I you know I got
you just do it get us all down to
Tallahassee and we pull up and I'm like
it's funny Chico text me right before we
go to show you that hey man make sure
everything's good and she go never does
that it's always like Chad you got it
for him to do that he already knew like
something right I think Louis is fresh
off the show so like none of us is on
our a-game to be honest we we get down
there in the door you know how to do ah
man you know when they do that ah let me
talk to you man well you know you know
we gonna have the money but people in
Tallahassee yeah I hear you bro I hear
you bro and I respect it but I can't get
on stage man but you know if you could
just do us a I hear you bro
then I respect it I can't get on stage
okay you want to tell them I know just
work with me I work with you oh wait I
got me we already here I'll wait as long
as you need me to wait uh-huh
so what's funny we huddle with the guys
I might live bro this is what it is and
these are my guys so they're like what
can he do
so he goes call it was cray he calls his
one do we shouldn't did this man but
it's part of story now he calls his guy
this guy appears like I don't know where
in his back alley behind
he's like hey man come take a ride with
me and I'm like no I'm good but I'll
wait pace right sad pig I'll wait as
long as you need me to bro I have a lot
of patience I have more patience than
you probably want me to he's like a man
so his good tries to wherever he drives
comes back with like this sack full of
cash he's like come to the back with me
and I said I did it but I'm like alright
so I walk in the back cold - like these
back go back go this dual pulls out all
these cash well they go on stage for
this oh yeah prize though so come back
to the thousand my youngest what he did
he's got this and then less and she goes
like man we already done he'll just make
it up so I will make it work watch it
trust it alright this is where I got
trust y'all you got it right
joe says supplicant was crazy my man but
not isn't that what hit it
uh-huh - so no we get on stage they do
that thing yeah they get on now it's
just that we'll keep that internal is we
get on stage
alright we get on stage they do their
thing and it's crazy like roasting these
guys you've seen him sure uh-huh
they're roasting the guys for like an
hour mm-hmm and like that becomes like
this classic thing and I'm like there's
no way in hell Joe was gonna put this
out and Joe was like nah bro this is
funny I'm like there's no way bro cuz I
was a sick because I'm thinking I'm
messed up I'm like mad at my soda they
put it out she going Lowe's kill it they
was cool as like man let's get out of
here not tomorrow got him back on some
flights and we got back I got back to
that later but not it's like it boy was
crazy puffs we enemy will puff he's like
man they had y'all on a chitlin circuit
and y'all in Tallahassee Florida who's
the one that blew that they all was like
Chad I'm like man I was like boy that's
authenticity and we tell you about we
show it off he was like and that's why I
love you boom I messed up my man that
was cool
yeah okay thank you so much for doing
this man I appreciate it bro is that
before we get out of here
is there is there anything else you want
the world to know yeah we have some
shows coming up okay
and we once ought to come to all of our
show so go to 85 South show calm there's
gonna be a link when you scroll down it
has all of our tickets they were adding
more Daisy Houston has been active about
getting us to come we're working on it I
promise you
Dallas were working on I promise you
LA we're working on in New York working
on so please go to 85 show.com pay
attention I think right now we got Long
Beach up there we got San Diego up there
Memphis is up there I'm missing the city
and then um Oh Charlotte we're coming to
Charlotte too and listen um also Atlanta
has been telling us to come back we have
not forgotten about Atlanta but when you
come back now that we've done what we've
done you got to do it right so we're
just trying to make sure it's right for
y'all so 85 South Shore con go buy some
tickets and subscribe type B Oh while
you're at it hot breath podcast my man
man appreciate you bro v6 yeah no doubt
[Music]
[Music]